[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum it's been a whirlwind
of a week sure has it sure has Ryan I
got a puppy did you get a puppy and I
haven't really slept so if I look tired
hey man it happens life happens you
can't always look average
sure self-deprecating
um it's your brand yeah man uh yeah just
great guests coming up uh carrion Moss
is coming up uh Paul house Paul Walter
Hauser unbelievable
um
just a lot of great ones we had you know
Brent Spiner and we had Jonathan Frakes
and the Star Trek Star Trek world and it
was fantastic just Marina backrin and a
lot of these are going viral and it's
nice to see that you know it's just it's
a little podcast there's a lot of big
ones out there oh we got to listen to
Joe Rogan we gotta listen to but it's
cool that people you know some people
are listening to this take a break from
the big guys come come listen to the
little guys yeah because there's some
real content here there's some things
that are going to help you I know it
well it helps me it's like therapy it's
great content thank you Ryan thank you
for helping me make great content I do
what I can and a shout out to my editor
Jason nelkin and my producer Bryce
you're rock stars as well
um
the handles to follow this podcast
please follow us if you like the podcast
Ryan at inside of you pod on Twitter at
inside of your podcast on Instagram and
Facebook how many times you think you
said that uh over a hundred
if a fan wants to make a super cut
a Supercut Supercut it wouldn't take
that much time because it's always in
the intro I mean but that's also just
that's that's a lot of time yeah don't
do that why would we want you to do that
we don't want you to do P.O box Fort no
um look the inside of you online store
has some great Smallville stuff some
awesome new tumblers that my sister had
made they're awesome silver and black
and sidey tumblers they're badass go to
the inside of you online store
um yeah there's that what else there's
uh sunspin sunspin.com the band that's
me we're gonna be doing a stage it very
soon we're coming back we're gonna do a
stage it play some live music and laugh
with you
um and of course patreon thank you all
my patrons for supporting this podcast
without you couldn't do it couldn't do
the talk Ville either uh patreon.comcity
you become a member I'll message you
right away as fast as I can and it is me
I do that
um so check it out there's different
tiers and different fun stuff and uh
there's these Lex Luthor Statues by the
way on the inside of you online store
this guy made these bronze [__] two
pound I suffered for the effing pound uh
statues for me from Smallville pretty
cool there's only like a few left all
right great guest today
um he lives up the street from me
uh he didn't have to go far and uh
I've known him for a long time and what
I noticed about him this time was he was
just a he was always a good guy he was
always he's super Talent he's a great
photographer great actor all that stuff
but like
I just he's a family guy he's a he's a
dad he's uh he talks about work and how
much he loves work but he also talks
about you know we get into you know his
father James Khan the legendary James
Khan and we talk about really
interesting stuff like you're gonna hear
it so uh I really enjoy this one Ryan
you're gonna say something let's just
get into it let's get inside of Scott
Khan It's my point of view you're
listening to inside of you with Michael
Rose
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
I'm not a I don't like talking about
myself I know you don't yeah but you
know today's the day today but it's it's
fun to I don't have to you know can we
curse or no of course I don't have to
[__] with you well you can't say
[__]
but you know what I mean I can be myself
with you because I know you were friends
I know you for a long time but you know
usually they're I don't know where does
that come from do you think that's like
just like since you were young it was
just something you learned something you
just don't like because there's a lot
like me I'm kind of all over the place
and you kind of what you see is what you
get and you know you don't need to see
that and by the way he's making notes of
just like things that are interesting he
might not write it all that's fine no he
just writes makes his own notes he
Doodles he has nothing to do right
that's fine right Ryan yeah no I just
keep track of the topic so if I need to
find something later I know what came
after what all right there you go that's
fair yeah uh yeah I don't know man I
feel like you
listening to people talk about
themselves sometimes is can be obnoxious
and I don't ever want to be that guy I'm
a listener I like to listen to other
people I talk to I don't know and then
also nowadays you say the wrong thing
you get in trouble I don't know you
don't really nobody really wants to hear
anybody's real opinion they just want to
hear what's like uh right you know the
um like The Virtue signaling right like
everyone wants to say the right thing
and do the right thing right and so half
of it feels like
it's it's not really you're not really
here and it's not authentic yeah
yeah I think I think you're right about
that so it's kind of like you know if I
can't speak my mind if I'm gonna get
lambasted if I'm gonna get all this [__]
why open up why nobody in other words
why I just open up to my friends my
family I'll tell them what I think and I
don't even think I'd have anything to
say that people would be mad at right
that's not to say that I have a bunch of
opinions that I know are not okay but
but political it doesn't matter what you
say you say one thing half the world
says [__] you yeah right yeah so it's
like if if you really you don't really
want to hear what I have to say I don't
even know if I have anything that great
to say anyway so I don't know I don't
know where it comes from I think I also
got in trouble once I said the wrong
thing once and I'm not gonna be specific
but it like it jammed up my life for a
couple months and I didn't even mean
anything I made a joke and it was like
you know uh it said something I didn't
even mean and it was like it was it was
sucked well why is it that like
comedians
can say pretty much whatever they can't
for the most part they can some of them
you got some of these guys that just are
are they doing it again I mean I feel
like I feel like I've watched I love you
watching comedy specials and I feel like
they're all complaining that they can't
say what they want to say anymore I
think Chappelle says what he wants to
say he's Chappelle but there you go
because he's like cancel go what are you
gonna do people are gonna still come see
me yeah cancel me I don't give a [__]
yeah what are you gonna do eat me like
that's true when you're that successful
and that Untouchable it's like they
don't leave you alone yeah but coming up
as a young comedian you say the wrong
thing that could be it right yeah I mean
you say certain things like you know
when what's his name Kramer from
Seinfeld went off I mean
so you shouldn't yeah that was right but
like career gone never heard from it
well because it wasn't a joke you know
he was he was pissed his true colors
came right that was see that's the thing
and that's what it's hard to
differentiate and Ricky Gervais right he
says whatever he wants and by the way I
wish she'd host the Oscars forever me
too
get up here and like do you you know do
you only thank these people in all this
[__] just [__] get up and take
this award [__] off yeah and uh I loved
it I loved it and it was just I guess
people were like you know yeah I'm a fan
of ass well you were nominated you've
been nominated you were nominated for a
uh Golden Globe and Ricky Gervais was
the host that year
really yeah so he announced your name uh
I don't know or somebody announced yeah
I just yeah I don't remember but yeah he
was there that was the highlight how
many award shows have you been to in
your life
not many I think that year I went to
that one and then I went I presented at
the Emmys and then I think that's it
that's it I think so do you hate going
to these things I don't hate it but I'd
rather not do you feel uncomfortable a
little bit do you like when they take
pictures at the uh what do they call
those screens the the red the backdrops
what are they called the uh what you
know those things that that you can get
the the that say the sponsors on the
back of it you're in front of the
whatever the [__] it is anyway yeah you
take pictures you're you're interviewed
do you feel like a nervousness that you
normally don't feel I have to be on I
have to look good I didn't used to but
now I do now you're censoring yeah I'm
I'm worried you know I don't wanna I
don't want to put my foot in my mouth or
make a bad joke or offend anybody right
and it's not even that I'm worried about
me I don't want to hurt anyone's
feelings I don't want to like I don't
know so no I didn't used to care or
bother me but I'm you know
when I was younger it was like you know
we went to those things and it was fun
and yeah you know now I'm like getting a
little older I'm like I've been there
I've done that I'd rather stay home and
watch TV you know yeah I understand that
I mean I I remember my agent used to say
I need you to go to the Golden Globes I
need you to do this in one year I went
and I you know I felt so uncomfortable
yeah I'm not nominated for anything I'm
not part of anything right why should I
go to a Roadshow or anything yeah even
when people say hey will you show up to
my thing I don't right I normally don't
do that anymore I used to right but I I
always felt uncomfortable like I don't
belong this is not my time but a lot of
people do that no I agree to go
somewhere when yeah I would never go to
the Golden Globes if they didn't you
know according to denominator Academy
Awards I think I got invited Academy
Award once to go with somebody and I was
like I don't want to go and you didn't
go to the Academy Awards I'd go for just
the swag but you don't get swag if
you're just there visiting is that true
I don't know I think when they I didn't
get swagged when I got another before
Golden Globe I don't think really yeah
they went up to the thing they're like
you want the sweatshirt I'm like a
sweatshirt I want a Rolex or something
like this nothing for me do you uh I
think I had to pay for my suit I don't
know did you you no usually they fit you
I don't remember we're gonna dress Scott
concert yeah I don't I don't think they
cared do you think as you've gotten
older
I mean look we don't know exactly who we
are well you know you and I were hanging
out back in the late 90s early 2000s
we're like running around we're enjoying
it we're yeah do you think they're sort
of do you miss that time period sure you
do sure what do you miss about it I just
had a really good fun life I mean I you
know I never had
uh I feel like in our I speak for you
too like our 20s were just fun weren't
they I mean all we did was have a good
time we were lucky to have careers at
you know early in our 20s and I just I
just remember having a good time I know
cameras were on us all the time like
iPhones and you could just go out and
have a good time I never worried about
anybody going hey I wonder if they're
filming this there was like one like the
you know there was like a group of
Paparazzi that you know you knew and
they they didn't you know they were cool
yeah it wasn't like yeah everything yeah
no cell phones yeah I feel like
some of the stuff we did back in the day
would probably
I don't know it'd be a be bad today do
you like promoting things do you like
well this is a good thing today we're
also promoting a new movie and it's one
day as a lion and I'm glad I love this
because then it would be it's what would
you say if you didn't though well I
wouldn't maybe I just wouldn't bring it
up really I I don't know if I'd bring it
up well I would probably say hey got a
new movie coming out tell us about that
yeah but what I liked about this and you
kind of downplayed it you were like you
know because you that's who you are you
don't like go you know you're like you
know it's good it's great cash it's
really a good movie and I'm like all
right because you're not like me like oh
man you got to see this and you and I
started watching and immediately I was
like oh my God you knew exactly what
this was
it shot so well in the first 10 minutes
so much [__] goes down where I love that
you're like this hit man but you're kind
of you have the you have a heart all
right you have and like the anti you
should not be a hit man but you are and
you're like oh [__] right you see JK
Simmons character
um you play Jackie yeah and you see him
you're supposed to take him out you got
this guy who's opening scene where the
guy's line on the couch the guy who's
your boss and he's he just farts and he
rolls over and says come on you're gonna
do this I didn't write the fart that was
I love sports okay and it's only one
fart it's not a fart movie guys it's
it's it's a very fun intense kind of
surprising and I'm watching this and you
and you call me like look he's he's a
cowboy he got off his horse or something
right I can't I can't kill this guy he's
like [__] kill him right what are you
doing and he put this mustache on and
you go into this place into this Diner
and
whatever I thought was going to happen
it didn't turn out that way I agree and
I love the surprise of it all and I I
love the connections and what I love is
also that it's grounded in this goofy
way like a Tarantino movie yeah or like
a comb Brothers yeah those are my
favorite kind of movies man when you
take really like horrible situations and
find comedy in them and humor I think
it's the hardest thing to do when you
succeed at it I think it's you know what
it works for me is watching you like not
ham it up you're very subtle right even
though you're doing some crazy [__]
right uh and you're a little neurotic
yeah yeah and watching JK Simmons
completely commit to this [__] badass
and when he's speaking you're like
this is for Real yeah because it could
easily be oh we're having we're doing a
fun movie when everybody thinks they're
doing this kind of movie it never works
no I agree and that's why I think it
works and it's got like Frank Grillo and
JK Simmons and Tara Manning and Virginia
Madsen I always remember her from
Candyman I love trying candy man because
you know the horror movies all around
yeah uh George Carroll it's like
and you produced it you're an executive
producer on this I wrote it and I you
know produced it but yeah there was a
guy named wrote it I wrote it yeah
there's a guy named Jeremy Rosen who
produced it he really should get the
credit for producing it I I just did the
like yeah I want a producer credit and I
helped cast it a little bit but he was
the producer did you call all the actors
uh not all but JK you called you know JK
I do we did a movie 15 years ago and uh
I've everything I ever write I'm
thinking of him for something and he's
such a he's such a no [__]
non-hollywood guy that like you know he
reads something if he likes it he'll
tell you if he doesn't like it he
doesn't have some agent telling him what
he should or should not do he you know
he if he likes something he does it and
so you called him said look I got the
script I think it's great I said read it
he said I like it if the agents can
figure out how to pay me what I need to
get paid I'll do it and so he want you
know you got to pay a guy like that yeah
of course you know I remember I did a
movie called pool hall junkies which
didn't very well but it was a fun little
movie
and they got Chris walking yeah and you
know he got paid a lot he was most of
the budget yeah he only worked like four
days yeah that's where how do we get
that I want to get that Jesus you just
gotta you gotta do something you have to
have a voice like he he's kind of become
a parody of himself yeah who doesn't
have a Chris walking and everybody does
walk and I've been doing it since the
90s and no one cares anymore me too I
remember when you used to do it when
people got impressed oh my God yeah but
I always feel like I do it like one I'm
one of the best I think I'm one of the
best too yeah we're not gonna do it here
no I could do it I could do it too you
you're welcome fine here we are it's
1990 all over again all over again yeah
but you know I remember uh
um so JK when he said yes you were like
boom we're Greenlight
no I mean this guy Jeremy he makes these
movies and he knows how to make them and
he doesn't rely I mean I'm sure there's
something that has to happen but he said
we're making this movie it doesn't
matter who we get and you know so I
don't I don't think that because of JK
the movie was Greenland I think we were
making the movie with or without him but
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
when you're at your best you can do
great things but sometimes life gets you
bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed
or like you're not showing up in the way
you want to
working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you
and who couldn't use a few better coping
skills to be able to handle all of
life's curveballs look
if you're thinking of giving you therapy
a try better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge better
help can help you be the best you
possible try it today if you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get ten percent off your
first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside
of you is brought to you by qualia mind
and uh if you don't think I use it you
see this this is it right here this is
what I take every day from months now
and you can tell I use it
because it's only a quarter of a bottle
left which means I have to get a new
bottle premium cognitive support Focus
memory Drive I take it every day with uh
anything else I have to take I honestly
that I don't take vitamins
I take my medication
you know antidepressants what have you
and I take quality of mind
and that's it you know Ryan I deal with
brain fog you know I do I I just you
know I forget things I'm not sharp all
the time you know those memory lapses
you know 50.
and uh I I didn't I told you this before
but I didn't know I was taking it
I thought it was something that I had
ordered
but it was something that qualia mined
neuro hacker had sent me
they had sent me because they were going
to be a sponsor so I started taking it a
month or so before I even started
reading about the product
so then I realized wait a minute this is
our sponsor this and I've used it and it
works so this is great this is going to
be easy to talk about so uh try it I
guarantee like in a month you're gonna
say you know
I it feels different for me it just
definitely feels I feel a little sharper
I'm not stuttering all the time
stumbling over my words like I normally
do it's really it really works for me I
I can't you know I can't say much more
than that it is just something that I
actually have to take
our sponsor neuro hacker combines 28 of
some of the most researched-backed
nootropic ingredients on earth into an
ultimate brain fuel formula call your
mind it's been changing people's lives
for years it's also backed Ryan by a
hundred day money back guarantee so you
have almost three months to try neuro
hackers quality of mind at no Financial
Risk and decide for yourself look I I
take it every morning it's something I
don't miss it's easy to talk about a
product when you actually use it a lot
of people just say oh yeah I'm going to
get money from the sponsor I I use all
the products and this one really gives
me some clarity see what one of the best
fuel formulas on Earth can do for your
mindset go to neurohacker.com
IOU
n-e-u-r-o hacker neuro hacker one
word.com slash IOU for 75 percent off
that's only 39 a bottle and as a
listener inside of you code IOU a
checkout for an extra 15 off your first
purchase that's neurohacker.com IOU to
try qualiamind with code IOU to
experience life-changing mental
performance these statements have not
been evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration the products and
statements are not intended to diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease
who would you what was your second
choice
that you that you were like if JK can't
work these dates I gotta have a backup
plan
I don't know you don't you were just
saying I got it I might have called you
I don't know to play JK yeah maybe I
could have done it yeah I mean not like
JK yeah but I don't know man like I said
I you know he's I can't think anybody
else now certainly not now if you would
ask me you know when he had the script
and he was making a decision I could
maybe could have had a thought but now I
don't know right you know you just don't
want to say yeah
why be disrespectful how many days does
a shoot like this I think we shot like
24 days 24 days where uh in Oklahoma
Tulsa Oklahoma was it fun no it wasn't
fun it was brutal man I mean I forget
you know look I haven't
made we I set out to make you remember
when we were coming up in the you know
90s early 2000s independent film was
like a thing you know we like grew up
doing it a lot of independent movies and
I feel like that's kind of either slowed
down or it's not the same as it used to
be and so uh this was definitely you
know the director John Schwab and I were
like let's like do an homage to you know
90s in independent movies
um and I forgot how hard they are to
make you know back when we were in our
20s making those movies it's like
it's not sleeping and you know being up
and was okay losing actors two days
before you started shooting all that
stuff was like yeah we'll roll with it
but now it just everything means a
little bit more when you get older and
you care a little bit more and you're
you know more so anyway there was a lot
of a lot of [__] went down it was it was
it was brutal why is it why is it that
when we're younger we have that sort of
fearless attitude we we don't think
about how many hours Something's Gonna
Take we'll work to the wee hours we
don't nothing we don't think about that
but I don't think do you ever think
about sleep when you're in your 20s now
if I'm like oh my God if I don't get
home I'm not gonna get my eight hours
you know that's exactly what I was at
Depeche Mode last night I went to see
the concert I wouldn't even go to
Depeche Mode because I know I'd be home
too late and I'd miss my sleep well the
car the concert ended and my friend
Ray's we got backstage passes to beat
the band and I go
and finally I said I'll do 20 minutes
and I did 20 minutes ago hey I said 20
minutes yeah and we got to go yeah but I
mean it's the same I mean when you were
younger did you have any fear about
getting injured no never now I'm like
worried about it you know I don't worry
about my lines no well yeah well I
always worry about that but not as much
as I do now yeah I mean like I've had so
many injuries over the years I know you
have too yeah now I'm like panicked to
do anything I'm like there's certain
things I will risk you know I'll do
knowing that I could get injured but
back in the day I used to throw myself
off of buildings do every stunt
skateboard pools surf big waves ride
motorcycles that didn't have front
brakes and were jockey ship I mean it
did stupid [__] that I won't do anymore
it's you know I don't know same thing
you just you're more get more thoughtful
and there's like a it was great being
young but at the same time you know I
think we're a little stupid then you
learn though from your dad because your
dad I remember going up to your house
and you were working out and your dad
was there and he was working out and we
talked and we got along right away
because he was uh so you're comparing
how many back surgeries each one of you
had right yeah I also became friends
with Stallone on set because of the
saint you had the same surgery you know
that [__] guy's got no bedside man
out there it was [__] but um
but your your dad had a lot of injuries
yeah wearing his knees shot his hips
what how many issues did he have I mean
I think my dad had 15 surgeries in his
life from what
I mean he was also an idiot when he was
younger I mean he also was you know
he he rode motorcycles he was a cowboy a
Rodeo Cowboy he did all of his own
stunts he I mean every dumb thing you
could do I remember when I say dumb I
mean we all do we don't learn from
mistakes and I kind of looked up to that
when I was a kid I'm like I want to have
11 surgeries you know like I I actually
thought like that's what makes you a man
you know you get a lot of surgeries
that's what makes you a [__] that's
what I become a [__] really well
ultimately now probably not all right
but what I'm what I the difference is my
old man he never he never got to where
we are where he became cautious he was
still wildling out till he was in his
70s and early 80s I mean he he did a
back surgery that they told him like you
can't do this surgery he's like I'm
gonna do it you know and he would still
um so I think the difference is I
learned as we get older we got to age a
little bit you know I've been
training Brazilian Jiu Jitsu for 25 30
years almost I don't train the way I
trained when I was in my 20s because if
I did I'd have more surgeries and I'd be
more jammed up but you gotta I think you
gotta adjust and
you know uh be the best 40 and be the
best 50 and be the best 60 not at 60
still trying to be 40. you know right
that's when you get jammed up I know I'm
still playing ice hockey yeah but you're
smart man you don't you don't do the
same stupid [__] it's not like contact
hockey I don't like you guys don't hate
each other inadvertently sometimes you
you're not like slammed against the
board nothing like that but it just
gives you so you're playing like a
little old man hockey you know what
though it's all young guys who are
junior hockey players guys that came out
of the NHL and it's it's fun there's
respect we don't like Jokers we don't
like guys who don't know what the hell
they're doing and they get their sticks
up in your face right because they're
not that good same thing with Jiu Jitsu
man at this age you like roll with dudes
who like get it and wanna you know right
not out there trying to you know win
gold in the garage that's the thing if
they're going after the they're going
they're scoring in men's leagues hot
men's league hockey and that means
everything to them they shouldn't be
playing with us because we were talking
about the other night I scored this cool
goal and I don't I don't brag but it was
everybody's like dude what the [__] and
I was like you know not going to
celebrate I'm like I learned not to do
that in hockey you don't ham it up you
just go you got to be humble you got to
reserve it let you they don't like that
[__] they don't like hot dogs no that's
more yeah no that's more gangster anyway
like back in the day remembering dudes
with score touchdown they just dropped
the ball in the end zone oh God now
they're [__] making a dance but I
love that man that was classy flipped
the ball to the ref like here we've done
this before I'm gonna do this again here
not anymore no you score a goal and you
act like you it's the greatest thing in
the world everyone's like ah that must
be his first goal you know it's true I
agree with that
um what was it like
well you know first of all I want to
talk about like you did 10 years on
Hawaii Five-0 right so like that yep
I remember talking to you and going back
and forth Hawaii is by the way like five
six hour flight yeah
was that a good time in your life was it
one of those things where you're like
you you liked it for a while and then
you were like sort of felt like you were
done because I kind of felt like that in
small villain but you had this contract
and like for me I had you know I'd
finished it out I had to do my work what
was it like being on a show for that
long and no one like I've done this I've
said this we've done because it's got to
get redundant yeah man it ups and downs
like you know looking back it was a
great time I got to live in Hawaii one
of my daughters was raised in Hawaii a
little bit like there's
you know a lot of positives but there
are a lot of negatives too you know as
an actor if you do the same thing for 10
years it's like everybody's seen
everything you got you know it's like we
came up looking at actors who you'd see
maybe they'd do two movies a year you
know look at you know I mean someone
like Leonardo DiCaprio he does a movie
every couple years every time he comes
out the box with like this new thing
like you're seeing stuff you ain't never
seen if he did a show for 10 years it's
like we've seen everything you got you
know yeah so it's like
it's it's hard to not become Schick like
it's it's like oh he's doing shtick you
know it's like I'm doing a new show now
and I'm like God I wonder I'd like it to
be as far away as possible as that other
role but it it's still me like yeah it's
like you've seen my whole bag of tricks
yeah but there's an exception uh and
it's it's also a lot of luck
somebody like Brian Cranston who did
Malcolm in the Middle and you're like oh
he's a goofy guy and then you see him
and you're like Whoa We transformed but
to your point he didn't show all that
stuff yeah but you know Hollywood I feel
like does not have a giant imagination
right like I did a procedural show for
10 years what's the first thing I get
offered another procedure yeah so how
Brian Cranston was able to be Malcolm in
the Middle and then turned into uh
a Breaking Bad Wayne
no whatever what was his name in
Breaking Bad Walter White Walter Walter
White
um Wayne White Walter White uh you know
that's that's rare you know so he he was
able to I mean I remember I I didn't
watch Malcolm in the Middle uh but I
just remember people being the guy from
Malcolm in the Middle is doing this it's
like yeah man he's an actor like he's
meant to do this thing but studios are
the same way yeah the same way as
regular people which is yeah which is
why if you can write or you do have you
know if you can can produce or you can
direct if you got as an actor like I
think that that's
the only way you're gonna tell them hey
I can do something else is if you do it
yourself yeah you know
um and um
yeah so anyway Hawaii Five-O there were
pluses and minuses I mean also
you know I didn't know what a procedural
television show was when I signed on to
do that I had no idea I I thought it was
going to be one thing and then it was
something else so
um but overall I look back at it as you
know a blessing and you know it was good
from you know I became I got married I
became a family man over there and I you
know I love to Surf I love Jiu Jitsu
like the culture over there fit me
perfectly but then at the same time I
miss home I miss New York I miss going
you know
doing movies you know I didn't do a
movie for 10 years
it's crazy because you're working that
was working nine months a year yeah
but uh but yeah man I I definitely look
back at it as uh something great but
there was parts of it that were shitty
you know do you uh are you one of those
actors who just loves to work you don't
care exactly as long as you're on set
and as long as you're acting are you
happy or you look like hey I I want the
content to be something that I could
actually be proud of or do we kind of
fluctuate because you gotta also have a
family and all that stuff yeah I mean
listen I've changed a lot I used to be
I never wanted to do something I didn't
love but then you realize man this is a
business and I gotta make a living so
sometimes you got to do something you
don't love
um
uh but as much as I'd like to think that
I'd like I'd be happy not having to work
and be retired there's no there's no way
you know I I I'd last two weeks a month
before I'd be like I gotta get back to
it we're creative people man we're not
meant to retire I think when you're when
I'm 80 if I've made all the money in the
world and I'm chilling and I don't need
a dollar I don't need anything I'm still
gonna be hungry to work right and
you know and the money is
you know I didn't care about money when
I was when in our 20s I was like I
didn't need much you know it's like as
long as I can pay the rent and eat you
know yeah decent food but now it's like
there's things I like to do with my
family and I want to travel and I want
to travel nice and I want to go here and
I want to go here and it's like all that
stuff costs money so I think it's like
you know it's a balance
this podcast is brought to you by Dove
men plus care guys do you get distracted
during the day thinking about your
underarm sweating or itching or emitting
an odor oh do those thoughts keep you
from showing care when it counts new and
improved Dove men plus care
antiperspirant with 72-hour sweat and
odor protection and one quarter
moisturizing cream helps you forget
about your underarms so you can be
present for the moments that matter
don't let underarm insecurities keep you
at arm's distance from the ones you care
about buy new and improved Dove men plus
care antiperspirant wherever personal
care products are sold this message is
sponsored by discover did you know you
could reduce the number of unwanted
calls and emails with online privacy
protection the latest Innovation from
discover discover will help regularly
remove your personal info like your name
and address from 10 popular people
search websites that could sell your
data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection but I'd like to have
uh you know I'll keep referring to Leo I
don't know why but would I like to have
his career yeah but there's only one of
him you know what I mean like not
everybody gets to just pick what they
want to do you know a lot of people I
did this I'm doing another procedural
show and someone's like why would you do
another cop show I'm like because that's
what they offered me and I needed this
machine like it's called alert alert
it's on Fox
um are you sure how many seasons we've
done one we're about to start a second
season in July but yeah man why'd you do
that well because it was the best
version of what they were asking me to
do like you know they didn't work they
didn't I didn't get off of y50 and they
didn't go hey do you want to start on
the new Scorsese movie like that didn't
happen I would have said yes you know
maybe yeah but yeah back to the uh my
point about I said studios are sort of
like every man they're not because
the difference is
is the the folks the real folks out
there who watch our movies watch our TV
shows when they love someone they are so
supportive and they you know they want
to see you work they want to see you
work but the studios are like you did
that now not the fact that you were
great it was a great show people loved
you none of that matters right it's just
a matter of
you know it's it's much harder now it's
definitely harder now with um you know
and I talk about this every episode
about all the streamers I I don't I mean
Chick-fil-A has a streamer out now what
do you mean they make they're making
content good for them Chick-fil-A yeah
by the way if they got the paper I'll
show up I mean all right would you do a
Chick-fil-A true but now nowadays is
like I think there's some ego with me
where
uh you know I wanna you if you're gonna
do something you want to be seen I don't
want to just do something and nobody
sees me I've done plenty of those
projects so you want to do something
that has the most
the biggest chance of success in terms
of
feeding your hunger of acting and that
people will receive and you could maybe
make an impact and do something yeah I
mean what's worse than putting your
heart and everything into something and
no one sees it that sucks we've all done
that yeah man oh my God have we done
that yeah you know but you know at the
end of the day
what are you looking at you're looking
at my [__] you and Steve Martin yeah I
was yeah that was uh uh I wore a
terrible wig see the problem when I was
bald is uh I started getting some movie
offers but I was bald and they gave me
the worst [__] wigs have gotten good
now now but they were so bad and so I
did a couple movies and then I was just
like I'm not sorority boys the wig was
[__] an atrocity uh that uh what is
that movie called Bringing Down the
House with Steve Martin it was it was
terrible but I I got to work with Steve
Martin I didn't care he was he was great
you know I got to make him laugh and he
made me laugh and I learned from him one
thing was cool was watching Steve Martin
at the end of every take going to the
modder and going oh yeah I can go bigger
there I can do this oh yeah and like
watching what he do where a lot of
actors were like no just you know I
don't want to see the monitor I don't
want I think it's different with drama
you don't want to go watch yourself like
on you know but how do you feel about
that are you sort of removed from that
like I don't need to see it as good it
like it depends it depends uh
definitely if I'm into the thing that I
did I want to see it but I didn't I
don't I've watched at a 280 something
episodes of Hawaii Five-0 I've watched
maybe four of them
and I just did a season of a show 10
episodes I haven't seen a frame not
because I didn't like it I just I don't
see how it's gonna help
help you it's not going to help me if I
don't like it it's going to bum me out
and then it's going to bring that with
me and if I do like it it's not gonna do
much for me I'm gonna go all right well
let's you know so I I generally I'm
gonna I'm gonna watch it if it's
something I wanna watch that makes sense
yeah how does it feel because I've
always known you not to be like uh not
to say you weren't a family guy but you
were like you know you've got a
Photography book that's awesome I love
that book thank you man are you gonna do
another one I did another one I have two
of them uh but no not anymore what was
the first one called uh volume one oh
tough tough title yeah yeah and then the
second one is called vanity
um but I'm I'm not shocked but like I
always knew you as a photographer always
taking pictures yeah and I was just like
wow he's also good at that oh thank you
so you have two you have two volumes two
well the volume one was just the title
but uh volume one and then the other
one's called vanity but yeah but I don't
shoot photos anymore why
I don't know man I think uh when I when
I was shooting I was shooting film and
when digital photography and phone
cameras camera phones became like a big
thing I still think that that's an art
and I think that people take great
photos with their phones or digital it
just it it wasn't what excited me about
photography like when I was taking
photos I loved traveling and having
rolls of film and not knowing if I
exposed it properly not knowing if when
I come home waiting to see what I get
out of the dark room like that's part of
what I really loved about it having only
32 shots you know to get what you want
or running and you know running around
and only getting one snap of something
that you liked now digital turned into
this thing where it's like let's take 50
and one of them will be good or and then
it was also a medium like I didn't
understand it like I I literally it took
me years to figure out how to shoot a
film camera and how to make it work and
how to understand exposures and f-stops
and shutter speeds and like it took me a
while to learn that and then digital was
like a whole whole new program that I
didn't understand so I just decided hey
you know I'm I did it the way I wanted
to do it and I'm not I'm no longer
interested the way I was so I guess that
means I was never really a real
photographer I if you see guys go get
these books or take a look at them
because they're they're fantastic I
wouldn't say that I mean they're just
they're just they're epic thank you but
but like you know but why can't you
still do old school I I I don't know I
totally could I just I guess my
passion's not there as a family you have
the acting career producing it's not
even yeah it was like my lifestyle at
the time really was you know uh it was
easier it was easier and I was traveling
by myself I didn't have anybody else to
worry about I mean you asked like you
know you never would imagine that I'd be
a family man I didn't either man like
the way I you know grew up in my 20s I
mean I should be I could have been a
serial killer or locked up or something
crazy but you know now man I love my
family like I really like my wife a lot
which blows my mind I never if you told
me 20 years ago I'd be in a happy
relationship I I would have told you no
chance you know but I'm happy with my
life I love my kids I like being with my
kids you know it's hard going away I
used to love going on location it was
like my favorite thing in the world to
go just be somewhere else for three
months now I hate it you're an old
school Guy where uh
I mean look back when you grew up I mean
you had a movie star's dad yeah it's no
secret yeah I mean you know I talked to
Kiefer about it and you know he said
some things about you know growing
because it's got to be
different I had a dysfunctional family
and for many different reasons and um
but what what was it like like growing
up that you could recall was it was it
he was always working no he didn't work
a ton
um when I was growing up he um
I mean I look my dad was he wasn't
you're you're a com no like a normal
actor guy you know he was really good at
everything he was an amazing athlete he
was good on a motorcycle he was a cowboy
he
he was he could play any instrument he
picked up anything and could get good at
it he was like a um
uh uh not a mimic but like if you should
if he saw someone doing something he
could pick that thing up and he could do
it he was you know I wouldn't even say
Jack of all trades because he was really
good at all of everything you know he
was like a master at a lot of different
things and uh to me him being an actor
was just something else that he was good
at you know what I mean to me he wasn't
like an actor he was just somebody who
was really tough really handsome really
smart
girls liked him he was good at
everything like
that's got to be hard for you as a kid
my dad is everything how am I going to
inspired it no I mean I think it made me
wanna do be good at stuff and you know
he used to tell me like he'd say if
you're gonna do something be the best at
it or don't do it and I think you know
if you say that today people are like
don't tell your kid that is you know
like he was like first places for second
place is the first loser you know what
I'm saying like that's how he was right
and I really appreciate that and I don't
think that that's like accepted today
and
um no it wasn't hard it was really
something awesome to look up to so to
answer your question to me he wasn't an
actor he wasn't working a ton when I was
younger
um but when he did it was just something
else that he did really well to me does
that make sense absolutely you had a
respect for him yeah he was he was as
far as I was concerned he could have
played shortstop for the Yankees do you
know what I mean or he could have been a
professional fighter he could have been
a Prof he was a professional Rodeo
Cowboy he was you know he he could ride
dirt bikes I mean he he just was good at
stuff so I mean in the movie rollerball
did he really learn how to do all that
thousand percent a thousand percent
crazy and like yeah he was he you know
he um
he he wasn't an actor to me is what I'm
getting at did he have I mean he he has
this innate intensity about him that
you're just you watch him and you want
to listen to him yes he was that intense
was he intense with you yeah I mean he
my dad didn't ever have to I mean you
know maybe he gave me a whack once or
twice bulb and whack but he never had to
he just looked at me funny and I was
like okay my mom too my mom was tough
like my mom you know whatever she looked
at me sideways and I just did what she
said I mean you know I've never
I never we don't scare our kids you know
today like right but I was scared of
both my parents in a healthy way I feel
like yeah you know
um but you know what they also you know
I don't want to sit here and talk them
both up like they were they were both
[__] up a ton you know what I mean
flawed and made mistakes and it was a
different time and but um but anyway to
answer your question he uh I just I felt
like I got to grow up with someone who
had a lot of amazing qualities to look
up to and now as I get older the
qualities that weren't worth looking up
to were also a lesson you know what I
mean he's like that was gonna be my
question right yeah he's a he was like a
he he was like watching a hero's tale
and a cautionary tale at the same time
and getting the best out of both and I
think man that's all we can do right
like get the best you know I try to tell
my daughter she was like this kid was
mean to me yesterday I'm like look how
that kid treated you all you can do in
life is see how people do things how it
makes you feel and decide whether or not
you want to make people feel feel that
way or you know what I mean like yeah
that's great advice and just like you
know you don't have to be that way right
yeah you don't have to do that or you
can choose to do that do you let you
know if you know you want to make people
feel that way you can do that I hope you
don't but yeah you know everything's
ever if we're smart everything is either
uh something to live up to or push or
stay away from and I think my parents
were so black and white in that way that
I was able to learn the good and and be
like Oh I'm not going to do that you
know yeah see my my father never
he had never admitted to all the [__]
that he had done he never wanted me to
know about his drinking and the drugs
yeah the women and yeah he he so he lied
to me yeah he made it like he was
perfect yeah maybe how he I don't know
in his way he was trying to protect me
and what it did was kind of make me go
what the [__] so I have to be perfect
yeah I guess you're perfect at right
because was it was your dad the the
James con if you don't know who the [__]
but that's true that's that's that's a
that's um
I think that's two things I mean not to
analyze your father and your
relationship but I feel like there's
there's Deb there was definitely a thing
and I think that generation of those
dudes who they didn't really look back
and go oh what did I do wrong or how can
I fix this or like therapy wasn't big
when your old man was a kid nor when my
man was a kid like I I approach things
now and I I go like okay what was my
part in that they didn't do that [__]
you know what I mean my dad would be
like I did a little cocaine I'm like
come on dude come on come on you did a
little coat you know what I'm saying so
it's like it wasn't to protect me it was
like that was the mechanism of those
people I feel like to be like Ah that's
it's in the past let's not even go there
like you know what I mean understandable
yeah so I think that and also there's
you know what you were saying too
there's I'm sure there's some some
issues and of course bad [__] behind it
too but for the most part it's just what
he said different kind of piece of
Scotty I love you
of course always felt that a hundred
percent see that's and and his father
never told him he loved him he knew he
loved him my dad used to tell I don't
want to make this whole thing about my
old man no it's not it's like five
minutes but he used to tell me the story
about his his father but my grandfather
was a monster I mean and I mean that in
a beautiful way he was a tough tough
tough dude his hands were like the size
of his fingers look like cigars I mean
he was just a tough he was a butcher you
know he owned a butcher shop in
Manhattan and he you know he was just a
he packed meat all day long I mean he
was just a big tough Jew you know what I
mean and um he would never say I love
you to my father he took his belt off
every night put it on the table if
anybody moved they got a whack I mean he
was a tough tough tough dude
never said I love you and then one day
and that's my dad grew up thinking like
hey I guess my father just doesn't love
me or whatever and then my dad started
getting successful and he would say pop
what do you think of this instead I'd be
like yeah you know whatever
and then one day some dude that was with
my own my grandfather in a bar pulled my
dad aside and go I just want you to know
that your dad was just in there talking
you up to everybody for hours my son's
this my son's that my son's this my
talking him up I love him he's the best
he's the best this so he just didn't do
it in front of him and that was that's
like that was my dad one of the
highlights of his life here in this dude
tell him that behind his back his father
would talk him up in the bar every night
do you know what I mean sounds exactly
like my father so so you know my dad
knew his father loved him so anyway
going back to like you know Hero's tale
or cautionary tale like my dad realized
you know what I'm not gonna do that with
my kid I'm gonna tell my kid I love him
every day which is something that he did
because he learned from his from his old
man anyway what's your favorite part
that he's done Thief that's the number
one 100 was he nominated for that no of
course not no today he would be today it
would have been yeah that was like a
normal you know that was just like oh
there's a good movie rollerball Gambler
he should have been nominated for all
three of them all of them rollerball's
still ahead of its time what a [__]
great movie I think they were trying to
remake it or something they did remake
it it was dog [__] but the the the
um if you put rollerball out today I
still think it's ahead of its time I
mean that's how good it was it was you
got to see rollerball Ryan thief too man
to me is Michael man's best movie I
think did you make your wife watch all
you like your movies or his movies or do
you want to educate her at all in the
beginning like hey if you don't know my
dad you got to see these movies it's
funny when I met my wife she was like
already obsessed with elf so she she's
like I love that he's great I cry enough
every freaking time whenever people meet
me they go oh your dad's a guy and elf
I'm like no no no no my dad's a
Godfather my dad's Thief yeah yeah well
that's nice to know because a lot of
times when you have the tough dad and
you see that in the world like I'm
getting hot can I take my yeah please
take your take it all off but I think
people perceive you at or your your pops
as like you know he's he was probably
hardcore and I'm I even wondered I
wonder if you know he wasn't there I'm
learning all these things that are nice
to know that like wow you had this deep
respect for him and I bet you got closer
towards the end of course right yeah I
mean there was a you know there was a
big stretch where we weren't close but
yeah at the end of his life we
definitely got close again and
um when I was younger man he was you
know from born to ten that was like my
my road dog you know I mean I went
everywhere with him and then you know
things happen you know how was I mean
honestly how was it how did you do it
because I know you kind of just went
away for a while when he passed was that
like I didn't go well Instagram I don't
have Instagram okay let's say this out
loud that's a funny [__] account okay
whoever that guy is he's a scumbag I'm
gonna stop following him don't follow
him he really I I someone sent me that
he wrote I need to go away
yeah that's not me I don't have an
Instagram account Instagram no but you
it's okay that you think that but it's a
bummer to me that someone you know he
posts pictures this is official no any
and he posts pictures of my dead friends
and writes miss you buddy like I I want
you know like I don't want to be violent
but like this dude deserves
I've tried Instagram won't even take him
down as I'm I'm uh it obviously gets me
pissed off but anyway I didn't go
anywhere no that's some dude flexing
like he's me
I mean how did how did you deal with it
how did I deal with death yeah well with
the passing of your father I'm okay with
death man death doesn't [__] me up I
mean it doesn't no it was expected it
was sort of like you were yeah I mean it
was listen man you know he wasn't happy
at the end of his life and he was having
a rough time and you know part of it was
I don't want to say a relief but relief
that he wouldn't have to suffer anymore
you know it's like you know
it's like he's like a he's a um he was a
a like a quarter horse who couldn't run
anymore you know what I mean or like a
thorough better better he had a
thoroughbred who couldn't run anymore
it's like it's that's no yeah he's spent
his whole life being active and running
around and then he's like jammed up for
the last few years of his life it's hard
to watch you know
um but um
but yeah man I think I think it's
important to to be um
to get older and understand and we all
got to deal with death man and I think
it's a hard thing for me is it yeah yeah
I mean it's like I'm not to bring it up
again but I said hey your your dog
passed you know like and you were like
oh thanks for bringing that up it's like
I was kidding no no I know you were but
I know it it was it was hard it's like
man I had a dog that was
I love her talking about dogs now but uh
you know as hard as it is to lose
someone that was so massive and so
important and
um
uh it was time man you know he wasn't
living a good life anymore you know same
thing with my mom man when she passed it
was like she wasn't living a good life
anymore right neither was my dog that's
uh that's why I brought it up I and I
didn't want to compare my parents to my
dog but I had you know you remember I
had the greatest dog of all time I think
when that dog died I'd never been sadder
in my life yeah but I was ready and I
was like she can't walk anymore like I'm
not I'm not this is a dog that jumps in
the air and catches balls like well you
know I feel like you know we we put dogs
to sleep that's the nice thing to do we
don't do that with people we keep them
alive
right right then I'm gonna do that all
right
um but yeah we like keep people alive
and you know we gotta we gotta be able
to understand and and be okay with death
or we're gonna be messed up later in
life and I think
you know not even not even talking about
my old man but I think some people like
I said you know when you're 70 you got
to be 70 man you can't try to be still
be 40 because you're not going to be
ready for we're all it's coming for all
of us we're all dying we're all dying
and I do it too man like I I we spend
our whole lives trying to be successful
so that we can enjoy our lives and now
I'm successful and I'm like oh I wish I
was 30 so I can enjoy more years of this
but it don't work that way we got to
work real hard to get to a point and
then you get what you want and then it's
like [__] time clock's ticking man who
are you what do you mean I mean I just
like you have this maturity this innate
maturity about you of life and like just
dealing with things it's like I can
understand now you're married with kids
you're a good father yeah you just seem
like uh it's not that you were I I
didn't really know you that well yeah
but I just your perspective on things is
just like
I I want to feel that way what are you
doing you go to therapy 20 years
okay good 20 years in yeah we go to
therapy town again Ryan what do you mean
couples therapy no no we're not a couple
we should though we should be a couple
but what do you mean you go to therapy
separately no what you go to therapy
together oh no Ryan I got Ryan into
therapy oh you've got him inside right
yeah man look if you're look if you
drove me to therapy
if you're if you're if you're blessed
and you got the the means to see a
therapist and you don't you that's a
that's a goofy mistake man if you think
all your problems are solved and you can
figure them out or you can figure out
yourself you're wrong you're just
[__] wrong I agree man I agree my dad
won't do it he's like you know what he
said to me when my when my sister passed
he said do you think anybody I could
relate to anybody like they understand
how I feel losing a daughter and I go
yeah people lose their entire families
in car crashes and planes and cancer and
you're not alone right go listen to
other people and know you're not alone
and how are they getting through it yeah
he just not for him yeah I mean it
wasn't for my old man either he never
went to therapy he tried but he you know
he he would go I'm dealing with this I'm
dealing with this I'm dealing with that
I go go see my therapist you go see my
therapist and he goes it didn't help I'm
like hold on it just doesn't happen in
an hour
it took me 10 years in therapy to go
like oh now I'm figuring out my
therapist told me the same thing 15
times 20 30 50 60 70 times and I'm like
oh now I hear what you're saying then I
forget it and he's got to tell it to me
again A year later you know I mean it's
a
uh I keep a Time
I don't care if I'm in uh you know
Morocco for six months I'll keep my time
and I'll call in when I can but I'm not
letting my time up you know and you
notice when you're not going to therapy
I don't not go to therapy you just go
yeah that disciplined yeah sometimes
we're sitting around talking about you
know nothing but
you know it's
I don't know I think it's it's helpful
and I think we're all we're all screwed
up a little bit I'm just lucky to be
able to
to have a therapist but
but yeah I don't know where are we going
no this this is this is great but by the
way I know you haven't listened to the
podcast but like
believe it or not I didn't I didn't do
this podcast at first I thought oh
you're gonna make some money but that's
not true you don't and it takes a long
time and the reason people started
listening was I think because
I started opening up guests started
opening up just and it helps you
wouldn't believe how this conversation
will help so many people oh that's good
it's it's Ryan yeah I mean that's the
whole point yeah it's the whole point
and I get so many people to come up to
me and other actors and like and I'm
like so surprised that just being
vulnerable just saying hey this is my
story you take what you want from it so
I appreciate that dude oh yeah of course
but like you've done you I'm like I
don't sit her name but you've done tons
of movies tons of TV you've produced
you've directed you write I remember you
wrote a script
I think you it was your script might
have been Michael Malley's when I went
up to your house
and it was you asked me to read with you
and Giovanni Ribisi and Mike O'Malley do
you remember that oh yeah yeah I know
was it a play I think it was a play yeah
did you write it I think so yeah you
wrote it yeah yeah because you're pretty
prolific I assumed it was you but like
all these things that you've done you've
been around royalty right like who's
someone that you you've got to know a
little more than just like oh hey and
they remember you like did you get to
hang out with Jack Nicholson a lot did
you get to hang out with any big guys at
your little star I mean as a kid as a
kid no man my dad had me around Cowboys
never bikers bikers yeah Hollywood he
you know that he used to tell me they're
all Goofs you know he didn't have any
Bobby Duvall that was his one buddy and
that's one dude I remember as a kid
seeing around and that was his friend
and he was something he knew you you
were around yeah that was somebody he
respected and you know but my dad I
think he used to he didn't I don't know
if he gave like Hollywood a good enough
chance you know because he was like a
tough kid from the Bronx grew up in
Queens
and he just came out here and he thought
these guys you know there's a bunch of
you know [__] phonies right so
that's why he went into Rodeo that's why
he hung out with you know bikers and
that's why that is so rare he was closer
to the stuntman than he was the actors
do you know what I mean his best friends
on the movies were the stuntman
um so I didn't know there was not a lot
of actors that I met when I was a kid
aside from Bobby Duvall but
um yeah he was and but you know and I
think he's wrong because in my
experience I met some great great people
in this business and you know what are
some of the great people you've met that
you really like you call friends I mean
honestly man I've never I don't
the most talented people I've met are
always the nicest people isn't that true
it's crazy and I used to think like oh
you know like coming onto the set of
Ocean's 11 I felt like all right
someone's gonna be a jerk yeah I mean I
was blown away I mean that was you know
I was 25 years old coming on there with
a chip on my shoulder like oh someone's
gonna be a goof here I mean from Cheeto
to Matt Damon to Brad Pitt to George to
Ellie like you can't decide who's a
better guy they're all such good dudes
you know what I mean they're all so
talented and and um oh Elliott cool
that's another one I I grew as a friend
Elliot yeah he was cool yeah my dad and
Elliot were close and I grew up with
Elliot's son a kid named Sam we were
always friends and so yeah Elliot and
Duvall I guess those are the two those
are big ones those are big ones uh what
was it like working with Paul Walker
you remember that did you work yeah man
that was my man
um I uh you know I met Paul at a reading
we did Varsity Blues and I did a reading
with him
and the whole cast uh
and it was the first time I met him we
did a reading at this the Red Lion Hotel
in Austin and they said hey you know
there's only one car per two cast
members
and uh we you know I knew that he had he
surfed and I surfed I'm like hey you
want to share a car he's like yeah let's
share a car that day we were doing like
donuts in the car by the end of that day
we got an apartment together and by the
end of the shoot we were best friends
training Jiu Jitsu together
you know wow going like he was he was my
that was like the first actor friend of
mine like that we were tight tight tight
and then you know my relationship with
Paul was always
um we didn't have to see each other for
a year and then we'd pick up right where
we left off you know we did that other
movie together into the blue and
um he was always
uh he was I feel like we had a lot in
common man he was a he was a downer of
dude and well not to say that I'm a down
door too but I mean we just liked a lot
of the same stuff
and he was a no [__] non-hollywood
type of dude I mean he's I still till
the day he died I'm pretty sure he never
really turned his cell phone on you know
I'm sure really I mean you know he like
he was always the guy that his agent was
trying to find and couldn't find he was
off on a camping trip he didn't give a
[__] about it I want to be that guy he
didn't care about Hollywood at all at
all
um that's why you liked him I think too
a big part of it probably but I mean
listen I liked him he was like into
motorcycles and cars and Jiu Jitsu and
he was Scrappy and that's another thing
people don't know about Paul Walker he
was a tough tough you got advice tough
kid you don't want to fight Paul Walker
you didn't want to fight him he's so
pretty that you'd think that he's soft
but that dude he was the first to jump
out of the car if there was a beef he
was the first to go protect a woman if
she was getting Mister like I remember a
story where he was at a bar down south
and some dude was like pushing his girl
around and the dude was like this big
bodybuilder dude like was like you know
what you got to say pretty boy and Paul
knocked him out and broke his arm you
know what I mean like he was a tough
tough dude wow
um and I never hear that stuff it's the
truth man he was you didn't you know you
I mean ask anybody who really knew him
he was he was a he was a real one man
and it's funny because he just looked so
he was so good looking and he you know
you wouldn't expect you wouldn't expect
it but he was a he was a tough dude man
and he was a good
um it's a bummer
um it was a real that's like that was a
shock that one stuck me because he had a
lot more to do and you know but anyway
all you can think of is I guess in those
moments is hey he always played by his
rules it was his he had a good life he
made his thing he did for sure that's
that's what you you hope for for sure
for sure but he um
yeah man that's just a dragon shitty
thing that happened that shouldn't
happen because anyway yeah
um all right this is uh called [__]
talking with Scott Khan these are just
the patrons the top tier patrons you get
to ask questions they support the
podcast they're awesome
patreon.comcity thanks for supporting
the show uh rapid fire
ready for rapid fire if you feel like
answering something you're like I've
been ready the whole time let me just
rapid fire this wait I don't understand
it's rapid fire I'm gonna give you
question and answer fast okay good or
you could take your time okay Kyle F
what do you miss about Hawaii Five-0
Kyle F oh Kyle F Kyle F uh Kyle F Kyle F
uh the lifestyle being in Hawaii you
know just walking around with no shoes
and surfing Jiu Jitsu the culture there
I really like the culture there Stone
Age how fun was it to film Gone in 60
seconds with Nicholas Cage and the rest
of that great cast fantastic movie uh no
yes it was fantastic had a blast and it
was one of those you know setups where
you're like is this what movies are like
and it's not but is he cool Nick
cannot be a cooler Guy come on I know I
keep sounding like I'm just talking
everybody up but that's what I mean like
super talented super smart super nice
and great to be around funny like
imagine all of his goofball characters
that he's played that's kind of who he
is man he's just like a fun favorite
Nick role in a cage role Raising Arizona
100 yeah Nico P what was it like being a
roadie for Cypress Hill and House of
Pain that's the next time you're all
going to talk about that okay
um uh I mean listen man I dropped out of
high school and went on a tour bus with
Cypress Hill and house of pain when I
was 16 years old there's I mean are you
still friends with be real yeah of
course I text him every once in a while
we met a few times and he was like yeah
he was just cool he would text me here
yeah I mean that's that that he will
always be like my big brother I mean I
haven't talked to him in years but like
if he called me right now and said hey I
need you to do this I'd be there in two
seconds
um yeah man time I'm 16 living on a tour
bus with the biggest rap group in the
world how much pot was there on that
trip I mean we would get it sent first
of all the tour was sponsored by
Graphics remember Graphics bongs
um we would get this is before 9 11 we
would get uh like a detergent box like a
box of Tide and they'd open the box
outside put like five ounces of weed in
in a in a you know like good weed
because we'd be in the middle of the
country where there was [__] weed we'd
have weed fedexed in this is before
obviously way before weed was legal in
in detergent boxes and so like there was
always just ounces of nobody ever got
together no because it was you know in
the in the in the what do you call
Leanne
when you told your dad you want to be an
actor what was his reaction any pieces
of advice he gave you yeah he the last
thing he wanted me to do was be an actor
he was bummed yeah he thought it was
going to be a you know baseball player
or something like that you're a good
baseball player he thought so
you were you're very humble I was okay
what position shortstop yeah yeah but I
was okay and a catch her I caught and
played Short Stuff
do you ever want to play softball with
me and my friends I used to play in a
softball league yeah I used to play in
this really fun game and then I just
lost interest well we do co-ed so maybe
even the wife it's fun no one's great
yeah I'll do that
well I mean is it like a league where
you have to show up it's like hey
Saturday at one we're playing for an
hour I've got to tell you man that's
another one of those things like I don't
know how to play light
and that's one of those things like I
will show up and play hard and I will
tear my ACL just like stupid [__] just
like but that's what I mean I like cut
out the things like I used to skate
pools every day I would go skate pools
or go to Supreme and skate the bullet
supreme or go skate but you go I go I
don't know how to you know my wife's
like let's go snowboarding I'm like I
don't want to go easy I want to blast
20-foot tabletops like you know what I
mean so I don't know how to play light
what will make you bad opposite handed
okay
then you could be go as hard as you want
yeah is there a fence no well see I just
want a fence so I can hit it out and
then just walk around you could jack
them yeah yeah yeah she said or he said
or they said they also Charlene C
Varsity Blues top 10 favorite movies of
all time first time you worked we talked
about Paul Walker how much did you love
playing Charlie Tweeter and what did you
love most well never mind that just that
question uh I mean still my you know my
most my most fun I've ever had making a
movie I mean we I was am I supposed to
be are they supposed to be rapid fire
like quick answers if you want it
doesn't have to be though
um yeah I I never I didn't go to college
I didn't finish high school so when I
got to Texas they set it up so we were
like almost like
a college dorm
and we had all these athletes from Texas
that didn't make it to the pros that
came and played with us so to me that
was like college for me we would I mean
I had cheerleaders sleeping on my couch
I had football players sleeping in my
apartment me and Paul's apartment we the
second half of the movie was all nights
and we shot all the football stuff the
last 40 days of the movie were all night
so we would literally go play football
all night go eat together in the morning
jump in the lake get on speed boats then
like go eat breakfast work out and sleep
for six hours and go back to work so it
was like the most fun I ever had in my
life I mean you really have lived a good
life I have man I've been lucky man
Jesus yeah uh last question Nathan J do
you still keep in touch with the oceans
gang any talks to bring the crew back
for another Heist you know the the boss
of that movie was Jerry Weintraub and he
passed so I don't think that that'll
ever happen I know people rumor and talk
about it um I'm still close with Cheeto
um and I think all those dudes is family
like I haven't seen George Clooney in
four five six years into him but if I
bumped into him I'd be like where are
you going can I come you know what I
mean so he's that kind of guy he is man
all of them you know I I actually saw
Brad a couple months ago and I hadn't
seen him in years and it was like you
know
just you know still good like brothers
isn't that refreshing Ryan they know
like the big guys the big stars are all
nice people it's always the guys that
are trying to prove themselves man I
that's true or you know they do a TV
show and they think you know or you know
that's it they're you know you know I
yeah yeah I mean it's I feel like
there's you see someone in that position
who's a dick he's probably insecure you
know oh it's always insecurity one day
as a lion is out everywhere now and you
have to see it it's an amazing I mean
amazing cast Frank Grillo JK Simmons you
I mean this is like if you love
Tarantino and the Cohen Brothers and a
little mix you like a little funny but a
little drama and like surprises and it's
a fun run run it's a fun run it is a
Paul run it's a Paul Rudd no it's really
fun man it's like I hope people see this
because there's you know the thing is
there's so many choices out there you
know it's like oh what do I watch what
do I watch but I think after they listen
to this interview they're gonna go hey I
want to go see this that's right you
know what I mean and I know my patrons
will check it out
and uh I'm just happy for you man you're
living the dream you're doing
you're doing what you want it's you have
a family
um what's next season two for alert
season two and then I have a couple
shows I've been trying to get on on you
know a couple TV shows I wrote man
during covet I wrote a whole season of a
show about a stunt family that I'm
trying to get on I wrote a show about a
MMA family that I'm trying to get on so
hopefully that one day they'll let me
make a TV show do you write every day
when I'm writing
how frustrated do you get when you don't
because I I've written a lot of things
and very few of them have sold me too
one has been made
what do you how do you deal with that or
are you just like hey I'm just gonna
keep doing it yeah keep going and then
also think about all those things that
you you know I wrote a movie
in
19 2002
that we made in 2007.
so five years yeah well they say that
about like um uh dodgeball took them
like 14 years to get that thing made
that's what I'm saying man so anything
that you've written you can always punch
it back up make it better or you know
someone will make it as is so I think of
all the things not all of them but most
of the things I've written a ton man I
mean I know ever since I know you've
been writing and so you know one day
someone might go hey you got something
like this and I go what about this and I
go hey let's make it I mean there's you
know I don't know there's a writer
strike coming up I got a season of
Television all you gotta do is push play
you know so and you just wrote this
movie
the one that's out the one that's out
well that's done we made that one days
alone just say you made it so you wrote
it and made it that's right there you go
yeah I love it this has been a treat at
first I was like I don't know if you
want to talk about this I know I was
gonna talk about that this is it was
awesome man thank you this is really
great I appreciate you coming here yeah
man thank you you don't do a lot of
these no I've done
maybe three of them ever I think so
what what do you want what's the end
game like what what would make Scott
Khan
absolutely fulfilled do you think you're
insatiable or do you think that there's
something out there like if I get a show
that I created that I wrote and I can
make that yeah but but then when that's
over I'm going to want to do it a
different way right like you can't
insatiable but not insatiable that's I
feel like that's like almost negative
right like we're creative people like I
said in the beginning if you're if you
gave me everything I wanted a hit TV
show that I created and started and you
know had all my friends in and you know
if I'm done then then I'm I'm kind of
like
it's like giving up giving up a little
bit it's like with acting you know if
you ever feel like that was it
then or or I figured it out then it's
time to quit you know like I still learn
about acting every time I'm like oh [__]
I didn't know this or that you've
learned stuff and what if you just kind
of lose your passion for something like
I did I lost my password for showing
photos right
I haven't written a PL I mean I used to
write a play every year no matter what I
haven't written a play in three years so
well what about
hypothetically it won't happen but like
let's say you're like I just don't
really love being on set anymore I don't
I don't I don't love acting as much I
don't you don't uh
I don't love acting the way I used to
you could quit
I don't want to quit why I mean two two
par I mean a it's how I make a living
but you've made enough to make a living
you're good 10 years on a show not
really no no man not really I mean yeah
to live
comfortably in a certain way but I mean
like I said I still want to travel I
want to do this I want your kids through
college all that stuff man you know I
want to do all that on my I want my wife
to sit in the front of the plane you
know what I mean like I want to go
places and you know
um I hear you no that makes sense yeah
but um but I do it because I get paid to
do it but if someone would pay me the
same amount to write and be a Creator
and not act maybe I wouldn't act I don't
know right and I look at I don't hate it
right
it's a lot better than you know digging
a ditch that's right you're right but
it's not I mean when I was in my 20s I
was like oh you lived in I wanna me too
million percent and thank God I'm not
like that anymore because I certainly
wouldn't have made been on Hawaii 5-0
but do you think now with the exception
of writing and creating that it's more
about
the outcome that it is the process
in other words if you're acting you know
you got to get up every day work 14
hours learn your lines all this stuff
would you rather just be like it's great
if you know it's great got a job I now I
want it to be finished
I don't know what you mean in other
words do you
um
do you like the process I do but it's
it's a really good question now that I
understand it yeah sorry no no it's not
your fault I'm a little slow uh I don't
think about results and that's probably
why I don't watch the [__] to me it's
all about process wow see that's great
especially as an actor as a writer
director different but as an actor I'm
just there trying to make it good make
my be honest I'm just doing that thing
that's it I don't even give a [__] how
it ends up in fact I was on a show that
was I was on the show for 10 years I had
a rule for myself I didn't care if the
camera was on me behind me I I had to
have one take where I felt like we were
just in the scene I don't care if it was
my close-up as long as I had that I
could go home and go okay I did my job
good today because you know how many
times how many takes this that you still
want to be good still want to be great
not even about good just honest because
you know we get to that point where
we're like oh I just I've tried to copy
and take from three takes ago am I doing
that like you catch yourself doing that
instead get in your head I want one take
where I was just in the moment where I
just listened to my partner or Partners
in the scene right if I get one of those
like I said I don't care if it was the
wide I don't care if it was behind my
head as long as I get one of those I can
go home and be cool so yeah I'm not what
as an actor it's not about the result
and I think it's important to not to to
to to to not be in the result right
because then it's a tricky thing man if
you're in a scene going like Oh I wanna
I hope it goes like this you're already
[__] you're already in the scene be in
it yeah don't be ahead of it or just
yeah man don't play if you can get to a
place where nothing is planned nothing
is rehearsed nothing is I've done this
already let me just see what happens you
get one take like that that was a good
day as an accident Eminem said that
didn't they you only get one shot
opportunity nut now uh lastly uh how old
are your kids I have a six month old
and I have an eight-year-old
and let's see what are their names Josie
and Maeve Maeve is the eight-year-old
and no other way around Josie is the
eight-year-old did your pops get
obviously got to meet Josie not me Jose
yeah
that's great right she called him this
is the only thing I'll talk about with
my kids she called him crazy Grandpa
that was his name really
I love it she to his face yeah hi crazy
grandpa that was his name his crazy
grandpa how do you feel about it I think
he liked it
I love this has been a treat man thanks
for coming thank you brother bye
uh it was a joy talking to him a lot of
times on the show you don't know how a
guest is going to open up or react and
he seemed like you could ask him
whatever he's like yeah whatever yeah
talk about my dad talk about this talk
about my life talk about if I like doing
something maybe it's just like having
shot in Hawaii for so long it just sort
of chills you out maybe that probably
has something to do with it yeah yeah
gives you a little bit of perspective
I'd like to live in Hawaii it would be
nice uh we appreciate you listening
Scott thank you for doing this podcast
means a lot to me and um you know
like I say many times in the podcast go
see his new movie it's out it's
streaming
um once a lion
one day is alive one day is a lion one
day as a lion
um great cast funny intense cool
Tarantino style Tarantino style
um
that's it for the podcast except for our
top tier patrons go to patreon.com
inside of you and I read the top tiers
names every show
and uh they also get merch boxes from
you every four months I just make nice
personalized notes I give cool stuff I
hope
um but it's really a great community so
patreon.comcity if you want to support
the podcast and of course I have the
talk Ville podcast
talkfillpodcast.com for tons of cool
small talk Ville merch and uh
Taco is a podcast that airs every
Wednesday inside of use every Tuesday
make your Tuesdays and Wednesdays with
uh me Ryan and Welling
and that about wraps it up here we go
top tier is Nancy D Leah s little Lisa
you Kiko Jill e Brian H Nico P Robert B
Jason W Sophie M Raj C Joshua D Jennifer
Ann Stacy L Jamal f
Janelle B Mike e l Don Supremo 99 more
Santiago M I just did a zoom with most
of the top tiers and it was like for an
hour and we talked about our life and
stuff as briefly as we could because you
can't really talk in depth with that
many people but it worked out it was
really fun I posted a picture for you
guys Chad W Liam P Janine R Maya P
Maddie s Belinda and Dave hilogy uh oh
oh [__] hello sorry Brad d Ray a Chada
cute baby Tabitha T hi Tabitha Tom and
Liliana a Talia M she was there
um Zoom bet CD was there chadam angel
amaran and see Corey K devnex and
Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy D Joey M
Eugene and Leah where were you last
night Corey Heather L Jake B Megan T
Angela Megan was there Angela F Mel s
Orlando C Caroline R was there Christine
s Eric H uh sh Shane R Andrew M zaroichi
77 Karina was there Amanda Jen B Kevin e
Stephanie K Jor
L yes jam and Jay was there last night
it was hard because some of them didn't
have their name underneath in the zoom
so I was like I don't and I was felt bad
but I was like how would I know who you
are we haven't met except I've seen your
name when she said jam and Jay I knew it
was jam and Jay Lee and Jay Luna R Cindy
e Mike F Stone H Miss s Brian L kdb
Aaron R Kendall L house J Meredith I
Charlene C Cara C Mary R Sheena L
Jessica B Kyle F Marisol was there
Estevan G was there making K was there
Mickey was there
thank you talk to your patrons from the
Hollywood Hills in Hollywood California
I am Michael Rosenberg but I'll
broadcast and uh way to the camera
we love you guys thank you for uh making
this podcast yours today
um is that right making it yours making
your choice
thanks for making this podcast your
choice
anyway uh and Ryan always hold on to
Smallville no okay uh the other one be
good to yourself be good to yourself we
talked about that on the zoom all right
be good to yourself love you take care
[Music]